darius kerner is ready to hit the icy
track
the 19 year old bobsled pilot has to
keep in shape the german championships
in the sport are just around the corner
the physics of what makes a bobsled go
faster or slower are complicated no one
knows that better than dr metin tolan
from the university of dortmund
to understand how a bobsled moves down a
mountain you first have to consider all
of the forces that act on it
say this is a mountain and this is the
bobsled on its runners a number of
forces are affecting it
first there's gravity which is pulling
it downward but there are other forces
that are acting against the force of
gravity
there's the friction caused by the
runners normal straightforward friction
and the second important force that acts
against the pull of gravity is air
resistance
air resistance is dependent on how
aerodynamic
a bobsled is and it's also the reason
why a bobsled slides down a mountain
faster when it's heavy than when it's
light
this experiment illustrates why the
heavy ball obviously falls faster than a
strip of paper
but that's only due to air resistance
we can prove that by pumping all the air
out of a pipe
then suddenly
but the members of a bobsled team are
also athletes in the end there's no way
around having to practice practice
practice
the same is true of figure skating
to look disgraceful nina maria knapp has
to hit the ice at least five times a
week
so are there any secrets or scientific
insights that a pro needs to know
one basic principle is helpful
the reason that you can glide quickly
over the ice is that it's always covered
with a liquid layer that's just a few
nanometers thick
but experiments have shown that this
layer does exist and the blade of your
skate is able to glide on it
but to really score points in figure
skating you can't just glide elegantly
over the ice you also have to be able to
spin
professionals have to master many
different kinds of pirouettes what
forces affect rotation on ice
principle of the pirouette is based on
the principle of conservation of angular
momentum
angular momentum is the product of the
moment of inertia and the rotation
frequency of the skater and it has to be
constant
both before the skater leaps and after
the pirouette is completed
you can picture the moment of inertia
before a leap like this
when the figure has its arms thrown out
then the inertia is high
that makes the frequency at which the
skater is spinning low
but the moment of inertia is lower when
the skater holds her arms close to her
body
so she spins at a higher frequency
that's because the product of the two
numbers has to be identical
a relatively simple principle actually
but when it's carried out properly the
dry scientific principle describes a
work of art